[Musique]
tout est sous contrôle on a géré la
situation comme des adultes
mon pire ennemi est en train de faire un
bûcher pour la petite pomme mais moins
fidèle maistre your elle m'a
confectionner une position anti feu qui
me permettra de me jeter dans les
flammes s'en va sentir la moindre
douleur venir on a un problème on était
sûr
[Musique]
il
voilà j'ai une bonne et une mauvaise
nouvelle la mauvaise nouvelle c'est
qu'on va te voir te déguisé en vieille
dame je touche je comprends rien c'est
quoi la bonne nouvelle je t'ai dis bonne
nouvelle pardon je suis petit il n'y a
pas de bonnes nouvelles
il ya une mauvaise et une horrible
horrible vrai c'est quoi la horrible
horrible nouvelle
il ya plus de potions ouais je me suis
endormi pendant la cuisson et ben c'est
pas verges le programme elle fabrique
une potion d'anti fun avec du stress
lors qu il s attendait ça c'est hyper
précis sa percée propriété quand c'est
trop cuit je m'en fous moi j'ai plus
rien à perdre mais je suis renversé le
chaudron mais j'ai un plan c est ce qu
on appelle j'ai créé une potion magique
qui te permettra de simuler ta mort
pendant une heure l'idée m'est venue
comme ça on écrivant une nouvelle sur
une histoire folle entre une jeune femme
et un jeune homme quitte ici de s'enfuir
pour vivre leur amour au grand jour
malgré la rivalité des taux calculés sur
la wii ta mère ta mère en chaîne
ok si tu affrontes un ellis dans cet
état là tu es foutu ma seule chance
c'est de simuler ta morts et furent le
royaume et en sortir ensemble
fais moi confiance avec la potion ça va
marcher
et maintenant que le duel au bûcher
commence trouve ça la fois très stupide
et très courageux de sa part mais je ne
peux pas cacher mon excitation à l'idée
de ce dieu très bien failli de dragon
mais d'abord laisse moi à boire la
potion de courage le plus neutre
oh mon dieu
ce n'était pas de la potion mais du
poison
bélie enfin quitter la terre il ne va
pas s'enfuir ou là là non il va mourir
oh la la la la bon bah tant pis l'âge du
couperet la tête quand il sera bien vous
êtes tous témoins de ce qui vient de se
passer 1
il a essayé de me frapper avec la force
d'un enfant il a voulu me griffer là
comme un petit château serait donc en
droit de le tuer devant vous mais je
suis un bon moi je suis un bon roi
appelle moi roi dragon et tu vivras je
vais prendre la mort à banon eux c'est
vrai basit à plat bon ok
c'est quoi embellir tu me déçois je
renonce à tuer tu veux pouvoir hyper
classe est français et là surgit sont de
par delà les arbres un homme magnifique
sur son cheval majestueux cet homme
c'était clarisse tu m'a vendu fils de
chien mais vrai prenez le pièce 1500 et
des bottes
alors moi je me suis dit elle va nous
ramener du par non elle sort une épée
d'accord pour couper du jambon
eh bien non pour défier release
[Musique]
alors qui est-ce qui va déflorer la
pucelle
[Musique]
salut je suis passé par beaucoup
d'étapes dans ma vie j'ai été au prix
mais moi j'étais en prison je tombé dans
la drogue
la même piqué ma copine mais à force de
courage et d'amitié tout est bien qui
finit bien
personne n'est mort à part des paysans
ben on va quand même faire changer la
déco mais l'essentiel r j'ai récupéré
mon trop doux délire faut qu'on parle
[Musique]
ah les femmes on les aime mais quand et
où volent le trône
[Rires]
[Musique]